mai mangiato fagioli ma di prepotenza di
gesù buonino d'arte ricordatevi ragazzi
che quando giocate agli horror ci sarà
sempre qualcuno che vi osserva le vostre
spalle sempre
cominciamo ragazza bella street i
ragazzi e benvenuti e sono video sono fa
vj lui e gigio lui e gigio agissimo
nuovo al colloquio se il nuovo no perché
l'ho già fatto ma la versione completa
ancora non l'ho fatta quindi ma poi da
lì che cosa diavolo abbiamo fatto ma a
questo coso momento in testa io voi
controllate che questo quando mi stupri
nel mentre ci vediamo tra poco ragazzi
ci siamo ma che bello ragazzi sono sopra
il soffitto questo sì che è un horror
chi cazzo sono per essere alto così
inizia un watusso c'è sempre il classico
testicolo di drago appena iniziamo
eccolo perfetto cervello reader mi piace
già allora è diverso da quello che ho
giocato l'altra volta vero fred che
fuori ma [ __ ] dai dai veloci
veloci che so già come si gioca non ho
paura di un cazzo e sito quali hanno un
medico tra boccino era per vedere se
eravate attenti ragazzi stavo scherzando
riprova che la tranche era solo per è
veramente stavo scherzando prima e non è
che voglio così facilmente io perfetto
inter anno intero letto inter livello 1
holding self perfetto questa è la
versione completa regali non ho ancora
giocato una mazza di questo se capisci
ancora tutta la mia rivendicata da già
sto tizio ok
sei sempre più bello stavo scherzassi
stavo scherzando lana era per chiarire
madonna che casino è più così e la
suoneria del telefono di qualcuno
ragazzi io cambia suoneria mette volare
i digimon che più bella stanza segreta
ed io ti caccia cagato un cavallo
tranquillo non esige un mattone fuori
posto ma ho trovato la stanza sadomaso
di mister gay ragazza si trova a tutti i
cristalli bianchi per una per una
sorpresa cosa mi spunta rocco siffredi
in mutande e che vuole fare il suo
domaso regalo entri in questa cosa e chi
vuole raggiungermi miraggio
legami leggo io ecco vedi qua c
frustavano le persone che non facevano i
compiti ragazzi infatti compito assi che
bea perfetto levissima purissima
altissima si lavoro ma 7 non potete far
trasudare dal soffitto della fanta lemon
per favore ci si meglio tra sono a posto
la fanta lemon orca sì sì di più ma
forse sperma in questo caso potrei anche
levarmi dal caso grazie di mortacci
rosso pipistrelli si su pista poi vedo
la luce di gesù gesù sei tu gesù non è
né gesù ragazzi non reggeva bene andiamo
avanti lo stesso anche se non è di gesù
io cerco gesù non trovi o gesù
andiamo avanti che belle queste lantern
è ancora che cazzo per favore non dare
da mangiare alla bestia notte sei
ragazzino andiamo avanti siamo entrati
nella nel clou del gioco ma ciao bella
gnocca che ha si salva la partita
addirittura la madonna chicca
salvataggio ok ma posso salvato grazie
zia sei molto bella bomba degli orrori
qualcosa mi dice che non è per bambini
perché infatti questa emozione prima di
entrare però di cavalli perfetto
c'è satana e satana che mi chiama
perfetto vado da satana che qua ci serve
la gemma se non entriamo che gemma ci
serve per entrare gemma gemma del sud
adesso sentito un rumore che dire
orribile e dir poco ragazzi comunque
siamo ancora qua che bello guarda mamma
ci sono le luci voglio anch'io questa
giostra
siamo a gardaland voglio andare in un
altro gioco mi piace questa mamma vi
chiamiamo già mamma ma ci sono i
pipistrelli mamma perfetto mi ha finito
io sento dei rumori come se ci fossero i
ragnetti ni che mi stanno nelle orecchie
prove amica che si gola entrata di una
discoteca questa è una roba ci hanno
niente questa è lei la monster che che
trasuda dal soffitto prefetto c'è sempre
la [ __ ] di prima ciao [ __ ] grotto off
la grotta di cucuta cui io sono sono tuo
amico sono fa vj faccio dj c'è una
chiave che cazzo ne faccio io ho un
appuntamento ragazzi con una certa a
samantha
e se riuscissi a trovare la seduta 90
eccola qui samantha amica ma sei tu
sempre più chiusa ma si è lei samanta ma
scusa ma come ho detto l'altra volta
samantha ri veramente molto meglio su
facebook login contratti d'arrivo fa
tutto un altro effetto e zia si
photoshop i ceti fa è mica che ti fai
tutta iocca ma col cazzo invece come sei
[ __ ] una minchia così bravissima
complimenti ma devi farti un po trucco
perché zia sei veramente male lo dico ai
ragazzi samantha lasciamola indietro
perché non serva una sega nella vita
ecco l'altra gemma del sud per fare
questa gemma del nord invece ma cazzo
vuoi tu non essere gelosa brutta [ __ ]
solo perché nomino quella gnocca di
gemma senti fatti una doccia per
cortesia sembrano i miei capelli quando
li lavo dopo due giorni perfetto che
sono più o meno così il culo però è sexy
devo dire siculo ce l'abbiamo il resto
manca tutto però dai un po di stretching
un po di palestra si fa chiamare gargari
il welfare la sporcaccione a samantha
saman tina samantha bella non vedo vera
che
ben active gola ragazzi per la gola
secca a perfetto mai mangiato fagioli ma
di prepotenza di gesù buonino
ed è comunque molto più gnocca di
samantha tanto per dire piacere fa vj
comunque non ci siamo presentati perché
se andate di fretta ma io sono molto
cortese no è che non me l'aspettavo da
un gioco così jump square del genere
perfetto grazie ospitale più che
ospitale ospedale però l'avete ascolta
sia lo conosci quello di prima non
perché era un figo ma vabbè sono uscito
fatemi capire copie guarda che è di
binario 9 trequarti non è di leggi o se
è entrato in un muro a caso poi finisci
male va bene per cassino e l'oscurità
vive in ognuno di noi ragazzi questi so
frasi da mettere veramente su facebook
in descrizione sotto tutte le foto di
facebook lo voglio ragazzi sei una merda
sì l'ho fatta ho fatto end of art
ok perfetto ragazzi è stato basta
veramente basta è stata la cosa più
triste
[Musica]
no no questi sono è perché prima mi
hanno fatto spaventare quindi sono così
quindi ragazzi è stato che merda che
cazzo successo quella perfetta si è
intrecciata anche la famiglia è stato
carino mi è piaciuto proprio scesi quasi
domani mattina prima cosa gioca questo
proprio niente ragazzi è stato bello
però basta spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto un mi piace per samantha che
poverina non ne prende più adesso su
facebook quindi mettiamogli di noi spero
che video vi sia piaciuto e cosa senza
se vi sia piaciuto assolutamente mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e
corneli video tratte trascrizione mi
piace per i miei capelli che sono sempre
più ordinati di gigio che è comunque un
figlio sano servizi discreti ci davano
prossimo video bella ragazza